shadow education secretary Angela Reyna
he might be relieved to know we didn't
just talk about brexit instead I started
by asking about the government's plans
to tackle the crisis in teacher
recruitment successive conservative
secretaries have increased the workload
for teachers cut the funding to our
schools and have had six consecutive
years of not meeting their teacher
recruitment crisis targets so we know
that there's a problem in our schools
and it's a problem of their own making
and just please save now started to
listen but I do think it's a little rich
to say that school leaders have been the
problem in terms of flexible working
when actually we've seen the numbers of
teachers reduced and cuts to our schools
which has left us with hardly any
support staff and the means to which we
can educate our children the same time
they the OECD says that the UK spending
on primary secondary education is some
of the highest in the g7 that's as a
proportion of GDP so the cuts can't have
been that bad can they well they have
and actually we've seen that we've been
slipping as per GDP on that oacd
we have we're not actually putting as
much into education in real terms as we
used to and that's really important
because as we look at the brexit
situation and leave in the European
Union we have to start skill in apparel
and workforce and many businesses have
been telling me that at the moment they
need those education establishments to
be giving our children the resources for
the future and at the moment that's not
happening and our schools are saying
that you know standards they want to
continue to give that good standard and
many teachers and support staff work
extremely hard for our young people but
when you don't have the money for books
when you're having to lay off staff and
make them redundant and when teachers
are having to leave because they can't
you know sustain their own work-life
balance then we've got a real Christ is
happening in our education system I want
to talk about your own plans for
education because what you said at Party
conference last September is that a
child's early years are those which make
the greatest impact on a child's life so
why is it then that Labour is planning
to spend twice as much money on
scrapping tuition fees as it is on early
years short start and their childcare
well I'm absolutely proud of our record
in government on early years we created
the Shore Start program in fact I was
one of the people that actually came you
know benefited from that when I had my
son at 16 and I think it's really
important that we do invest in early
years and we have put additional funding
into early years the government is
caught sure start from them we've lost
over 1200 short out programs across the
UK and that's devastated and we've also
seen that the 30 hours of free childcare
that the government promised has not
been being able to be delivered by the
private providers because they're not
funding it adequately we've got to make
sure that our early years is funded
successfully because that's really where
you can make the biggest impact on
social mobility
he's now sure that every child can do
well you see that's the point though
isn't it you talk passionately about it
I understand it you get it you
understand that early years is the time
that you can really make a difference
the child's life so what I'm trying to
understand is why labour is spending
just 5.3 billion pounds on childcare
elyes and Shore start an 11 point 2
billion on scrapping university tuition
fees and maintenance grants when all the
evidence suggests that if you want to
tackle social mobility
you've got to target children younger
than when they go to university is it
because if you were in charge you'd be
doing things differently well we've made
sure that the early years program that
we have would make sure that every two
to four year old would get the 30 hours
of free childcare regardless of their
circumstances which is different to the
Conservatives
because they're children that need it
the most we'll get that support we did
say that we would scrap swishin fees and
we would bring back maintenance grants
and maintenance support and I think
that's fundamentally important because
our national education service will be
free at the point of need and we'll be
there for every single person to use I
think that will transform Britain I
think it's a really good thing I think
it speaks to our values so not only will
we make sure that the early years is
there to support people at the start of
life but we will make sure lifelong
learning and education is free for all
when they need it do you really think
that scrapping university fees will
transform Britain because according to
the IFS it's the high earning graduates
who'll benefit the most from that policy
lots of people would say it's just a bun
for middle class kids
well it's not I think you know coming
from a working-class background myself I
had the opportunity to go to university
for free if I wanted it I think we all
benefit from people who go to university
and get good jobs and get skilled we'll
work fast we need that going into our
economy in the future I think it's an
important value that we have and it does
make an impact on our young people if
they're having to leave University in
57,000 pounds of debt and of course it's
those that need the maintenance support
that could come away from university
with the biggest amount of debt I think
that's really scary for our young people
I think it's a wrong thing for the
government to do and the government will
say most of that tuition fees never paid
off but if you're that young person
having that saddled round your neck for
all those years I think that's really
upsetting for them I think it's a value
that we can afford I think it's the
right thing to do and it's what labor
will do when we get into power now we
have to talk about brexit of course and
this weekend P is going to be voting on
a series of amendments one of them and
could be the you vet Cooper amendment
which effectively seeks to rule out No
Deal by delaying brexit if MPs can't
reach agreement so I'd really appreciate
a clear answer on this because people
are really worried about what's
happening with Bret said we'll labor
back that me about Cooper amendment
labor we'll do whatever it takes to
avoid a No Deal brexit so if that's the
only option that we have been it's
something we will seriously consider I
want to reason a genuinely to listen to
Parliament and to reach a consensus
she's I think many of her red lines at
the moment possibly can be what we've
said is we've put our amendment down let
me be as clear as I possibly can be for
the people that are listening to this
program we've put our amendment down we
said we've respected the result of the
referendum we want to find a deal we
want a customs union we want protection
for environment consumer employment we
said that all along Theresa May will not
budge on the red lines she's forcing us
trying to bully us into a no deal
scenario we will do whatever it takes
through Parliament to stop that No Deal
scenario from happening if that means
back in an amendment then
we'll do that okay and now the front
benchers own amendment and puts the
option of a second referendum on a table
and but recently your party chairman in
Lavery has said that asking the boaters
to vote again on an issue they have
already given an answer on until they
come up with the right answer risks
serious damage to the relationship
between many citizens and politicians at
Westminster so I'm interested in your
own view on this what do you think
having a second referendum or labor
backing Suffern second referendum would
do to democracy
well our conference motion was very
clear and we said we wouldn't rule that
out but let me be clear I think that if
we end up in the second referendum then
others politicians has failed the public
we fail to be able to do our job I will
see that as a really difficult situation
for us all to be in I don't think people
want to see a delay in article 50 I
don't think people want to see us in the
second referendum they want to see
parliamentarians working together to
carry out what happened in the result of
the referendum to get the best possible
deal we can for Britain moving forward
and the only way we can do that next
week is by Theresa May actually
genuinely working across Parliament and
looking at her red lines and seeing how
she can build that consensus I still
think that can happen what Theresa May
has to be willing to put her own views
aside and to work with Parliament and
for the last two and a half years
unfortunately she's not been willing to
do that I hope she does now next week
how would you vote if there was another
referendum and do you think that leave
would just win again I would be really
worried about a second referendum to be
honest I don't think that people
necessarily it will expect the result
that they get I think if anything it
will be very narrow and worst-case
scenario is it will be a very narrow
remain and then what we're going to have
the best of three I think it would be
really difficult for the UK to be in
that situation you know like I say I
respect the result I probably would vote
remain I would probably vote remain and
the reason I'd vote remain is I've seen
over the last two and a half years all
the analysis that we've got at the
moment and
you know we're in the European Union we
get benefits have been part of the
European Union and I believe that would
be the right thing for the UK I believe
that at the start of this process when I
made my first vote and I still believe
that to be the case but I also believe
in democracy and people made a decision
now I've heard people say well they were
lied to except xual you know I've pulled
Damien Heinz up five times in terms of
his dodgy stats and you know every
manifesto you only get half of it
implemented normally so you know there
is always mistruths as we'd say in
Parliament and you know I understand
that people's frustration but I really
don't see that the UK has moved
significantly away from where they were
originally on that original decision so
I think Parliament has just got to get
on with it now